as a developer i quickly got into the
habit of pushing to get help multiple
times a day
so it surprises me when i hear that
operations teams are tackling their
infrastructure automation
with a lot of manual processes hey
everyone my name is cy venom and today i
want to talk about ansible
ansible is an open source infrastructure
automation tool initially developed by
red hat
and enables you to tackle kind of all of
the major challenges that come with
infrastructure
it enables you to do so with code
or in other terms infrastructure as code
now ansible has three major kind of uses
and i'll start with the first one
because this is generally the one that
people tend to gravitate to
when they hear infrastructure automation
and that's
the provisioning use case so the first
step
of kind of any infrastructure store
you've got to have some infrastructure
in the first place
so let's say that using ansible we've
already spun up some
environment let's say it's a vpc
and my favorite cloud provider and
within this vpc
i've got three virtual machines so we'll
say
we've got one two
and then a third one as well now
these set of virtual machines are going
to essentially be our
set of hosts in the ansible world we're
going to call this
an inventory so it's basically the set
of hosts that ansible can work against
so what we're going to call this is
an inventory now within this inventory
we can actually create even more
sub categorizations and ansible calls
this patterns
so let's say these virtual machines have
different you know underlying tasks and
use cases and services that they're
going to be running
so these first two virtual machines will
call them web
because they're going to be used for web
servers
and then this last one
we're going to call this db because
we're going to run my sql database on it
so there we go we've got our
infrastructure we've got that provision
kind of step
already done and i want to jump to the
second thing that ansible is really good
at
it's config management and actually i'd
say this
is kind of the main use case that most
people think about
when they first start to use ansible and
this kind of refers to the ability
to configure your actual infrastructure
so a simple example would be something
like operating sys operating system
patches
or maybe making sure a certain service
is running maybe installing some service
onto a virtual machine
so in our use case today let's focus on
that let's focus on how we can do config
management
with these virtual machines now one of
the key
tenets of ansible is that it's
declarative
now out there there's kind of um
the notion that ansible is can be both
declarative as well as procedural or
imperative
and the idea is that um you know with
ansible
do you declare what you want instead of
focusing on how it gets there
but in essence it can also be considered
procedural because the underlying
tasks that run are procedural in nature
but as a user of ansible you're taking
advantage of the declarative aspect of
it meaning
you define what you want rather than how
to get to whatever it is that you need
now today what we want is to be able to
run some tasks
against those vms let's say we want to
run some os patches and then install a
programming language and then install
mysql
so we'll need is a playbook so
that's what we'll start with first we'll
create an ansible playbook
and as the name indicates a playbook is
going to be a book
of tasks or a set of of plays rather
now our first play we want to run this
against
all of our hosts and we want to just run
a security patch we want to make sure
they're all running the same version of
the same operating system
so that will be our first play so a play
is going to be
kind of consisting of three main things
you need a name for that play
you need the host that it's going to run
against and you need the actual tasks
that will run
now in this particular play
let's say that we've got the hosts set
to
all because we want to run this against
all the hosts and
as far as the tasks
we'll define some set of tasks like
security patching and that kind of thing
now key thing that i want to mention
here uh ansible takes
takes advantage of yaml to do its kind
of declarative nature of
being able to declare what you want so
this would this is obviously not
a valid yaml but in the real world you
know when working with ansible this
would be in yaml format
so that'll be our first play running
against all of the hosts in our
inventory
now let's let's create some more plays
here let's create a play
that runs directly against the hosts
for our web servers so we call that
web right and this is going to have a
set of tasks
maybe we need to do something like
install go and install python
maybe install some other services that
are specific to our web
servers and finally we'll create one
more play in this playbook
and for this one we'll set the host to
be
our db and then for
instead of tasks let's talk about
something called roles
ansible has a concept of roles which
basically enable you to
group together actions that you run
multiple times so instead of having to
define all of the tasks every single
time
you can just define the roles
and that will take advantage of you know
the underlying modules and tasks that
need to be run
by the way a playbook is one way of
grouping together
a set of tasks that you need to run uh
it's a declarative way of doing it
but if you really want to keep things
procedural imperative you can actually
run
one-off tasks by themselves and and do
so in a
in an imperative way or a procedural way
but this is kind of the way you would do
a fully declarative approach to automate
a set of tasks
against you know the set of hosts in
your inventory
so this is our playbook and we want to
execute this now
that's going to bring me to my second
tenet of ansible
and that's the fact that it's agentless
now ansible is agentless in in the sense
that
like a lot of other infrastructure
automation tools you
unlike a lot of other infrastructure
automations you don't actually need to
install an
agent on the vms that were provisioned
so ansible is able to take advantage of
ssh
to actually directly go into those vms
and run the tasks that it needs to
so let's see what that looks like right
so we take our playbook
and as a user we'll execute ansible
and ansible can execute you know and
most unix-like environments
so we'll execute our playbook and
it'll run against our virtual machines
and there we go we're happy
but here's one thing to think about now
chances are we wouldn't be running
ansible on our local machine
right at the end of the day it has to
store ssh keys and a lot of
kind of other secure configuration and
you're not really trying to run
automation off your local machine
so there's a capability out there called
awx
or ansible tower which is the downstream
project of the open source awx
and that's basically a graphical
interface
uh and set of apis that enable you
to run ansible and operationalize it
across your organization
so whether you're using ansible or
ansible tower a user will come in
execute that playbook and there we go
we'll we'll have our config management
executed
now the third aspect that i want to talk
about
with ansible is the fact that it's item
potent
now what exactly does that mean so item
potent refers to an operation
that can be run multiple times without
changing
beyond the initial application in other
terms
the first time i run this operation it
should recognize that the security
patches need to be installed the
the services need to be installed the
python
and go and mysql or whatever needs to be
installed has to be done
the second time i execute that same
playbook it's going to recognize it's
already done it
and it's going to say hey nothing needs
to be done but let's say i come back
my second day and i say oh we need to
actually update
the operating system version from you
know 1.0 to 1.1
and we run this same playbook and
ansible or ansible tower
and then recognize it and says hey that
operating system has changed but nothing
else did
it's going to execute the only action
needs to to kind of resolve
that difference now one thing to
consider
all of these tasks have underlying
modules that power them
and you want to make sure make sure that
the modules themselves are programmed in
a way that's item potent
and this is important and it kind of
brings me to my last point here
is that ansible is community driven
that means that if i'm trying to do
these things in a playbook that i kind
of outline today
chances are someone out there has
already developed the playbooks the
modules the tasks that i need
to actually do those operations those
are basically published as collections
in what's called
ansible galaxy which is a repository
where developers can kind of contribute
their ansible
kind of modules or playbooks or tasks
whatever they might have created in the
ecosystem
that's one of the great things about
ansible is that it's so community driven
that chances are
whatever i'll need to do i'll be able to
find in that galaxy
ansible galaxy the one kind of
disclaimer i'll say
make sure run these operations locally
make sure they're item potent
make sure that you know executing them
multiple times
responds in a way that's kind of
predictable
so all that being said we've kind of
talked about how ansible is a
declarative language
it doesn't require an agent to be able
to execute in these
kind of end environments in these
virtual machines it's item potent
based on the modules that you're using
to enable you to avoid things like
config drift
by making sure that any changes that you
make should be done
in your infrastructure automation story
whether it's playbooks or roles or
modules
and then finally you know you can rest
easy knowing that chances are whatever
you need to automate
is available in the community now the
third use case i mentioned there are
three things that you can do with
ansible
it's going to be app deployment now i'm
not going to go into too much detail
detail here today about the app
deployment use case but the fact is you
can use ansible to then take it a step
further and deploy
your actual web applications and
workloads into the virtual machines
it's also a capability available by
ansible i hope this was helpful
if you like this video or have any
comments be sure to drop a like or
comment below
stay tuned and follow us for more videos
like this in the future
thank you